[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
welcome, everybody,
to this session, where I'm going
to talk a little bit about what
to consider when
developing mobile apps.
And I'm really happy
to hear the playlist
that they were
playing just before
as you were all coming in.
Because I did a talk upstairs
in the previous slot,
and the song that they
played was like, "What Do You
Do When Things Go Wrong?"
And the microphone
failed and the clock
failed in the middle of my talk.
So thankfully, the song
they just played for you now
is "This Is What You Came For."
So thank you for
playing that song.
So hopefully this is
what you came for.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about what to consider
when developing mobile apps.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
I work primarily on Firebase,
but I do some geo work,
and I do some
cloud work as well.
And I want to talk a little bit
about some of the statistics--
oop, my slides are--
so I want to talk a
little bit about some
of the statistics of developers
who are successful at building
apps and some of the habits of
highly successful developers.
And the first statistic that
I'll show is this number, 51%.
Some research has found
that 51% of developers,
as of the end of
2016, fall-- and this
is mobile developers--
fall below what
was termed the poverty line,
where the poverty line is
that their app makes
$500 or less per month.
So 51% of developers are
falling into that bucket,
and that's a lot of developers,
and that's a lot of apps.
And once upon a time, there
felt like there was a gold rush
for building mobile apps,
that you could build anything,
you could put it
in the App Store,
in the Play Store,
and you could do
really, really well.
But as of 2016, the majority,
51%, are not doing so well.
29% of developers are above
the successful line, the highly
successful line, of making--
excuse me-- making
$5,000 or more per month
off of their applications.
So that's a pretty
good number, 29%.
I know I'd rather be in
that bucket than in the 51%.
So what we've been
doing is we've
been doing a lot of
research into what
makes a successful
application, what
allows an application to be--
what allows an application
developer to be successful,
and what are some of the
habits that they have.
So breaking down those
numbers a little bit further
gives this bar chart.
Now earlier, I mentioned 51%
are below the poverty line.
But the vast majority of them,
that big bar on the left,
are way below the poverty line.
They're making less
than $100 per month.
So it's about 39% are on that.
About 12% are
between $100 to $500.
But then, there's this
small bar over on the right.
And these are the folks who are
making $25k or more per month
off of their applications.
Now, what do they
do that I don't do?
What do they do that the rest
of the folks here don't do?
What are some of their habits?
You know, one of them that we
took a look at is that 88%--
whoops-- 88% of them are
targeting three platforms.
They're targeting Android,
iOS, and mobile web.
So the vast majority of the ones
who are extremely successful
are going beyond
a single platform.
So like, it would be
point of advice number one
that, if you're
building something,
don't focus on a
single platform.
88% of the folks on the
right-hand side of this diagram
did not.
They focused on Android,
iOS, and the web.
And as a result, they're
in the $25k-plus club.
There's a lot of other
things that they do.
So first of all, for
example, outsourcing--
a lot of the logic
that you would normally
have to build and
roll for yourself,
for example, authentication--
it's really, really difficult
to build a secure
authentication system.
It's even more difficult
for you to maintain that,
because it's a
constantly moving target.
There are new vulnerabilities
being found all the time.
And if you build something
and roll it yourself,
you are beholden to your
developers and your SREs
to be able to maintain
that while it's
under attack, whereas the highly
successful folks have moved
more into a federated identity.
So you've probably
seen, most apps nowadays
allow you to sign
in with Facebook,
or sign in with Google, or
sign in with Twitter, GitHub,
and other providers.
So having that ability
to be able to offload
all of the work of building
and maintaining a security
infrastructure is something
that would then allow them--
if you were at the keynote
yesterday, one of the most
poignant things that
I remember hearing
was when Eric Schmidt was
talking about, you know,
the most difficult
thing to do is
to find the developers
to do the job
and to get your developers
focused on doing a job.
Because most of you
are here because you're
software developers.
And you're a really
precious asset.
You're a really precious
resource to your company.
And as a result, the folks
over on the right-hand side
here have had their
software developers
focused on building the business
value of the company as opposed
to building infrastructure
that would allow
them to run their applications.
So with all of that in
mind, we built Firebase.
Now, sometimes when
I talk about this--
and there's always somebody
in the audience that say,
wait a minute, you
didn't build Firebase.
You bought it, all right?
And there's a little
bit of a joke in there.
bit of truth there.
Because you know, when
we acquired Firebase,
we acquired some of the
technology at Firebase
like the realtime database that
I'm going to be talking about.
But Firebase as a whole
goes way beyond just
the realtime database
and authentication.
It's a suite of
products that we've
designed to allow you to
use your existing APIs,
be they iOS APIs, or Android
APIs, or JavaScript APIs,
to build apps, to build sites,
but to greatly enhance them
by having this suite of services
that makes it easier for you
to develop using things
such as a realtime database,
using things such as the
functions that were mentioned
this morning, using things
such as, like, authentication
to be able to have all of that
available to you as a service.
But then also, one of the
habits of the highly successful
developers that we
saw was that they
had a programmatic,
systematic way
of growing their application.
They didn't just build
something, throw it
into the App Store,
do a marketing spend,
and then sit back and wait.
So being able to grow
your application and have
technologies in place-- and I'll
talk about them a little bit--
that you can have to
grow your application
is very, very important.
And that's the second of
the pillars of Firebase.
The third of the pillars
of Firebase, of course,
is being able to earn.
There's two ways that you
typically earn from an app.
Number one is you charge
for it, or number two
is you put advertising in it.
And as a result,
in Firebase, we've
brought the mobile advertising
APIs from Google into Firebase
to make it really,
really, super easy
for you to be able
to build these apps,
to grow these apps,
and for you to be able to earn
money from your apps and sites.
And then finally, we bring that
all together with Analytics.
The other habit of the
highly successful developers
was they know what
their users are doing.
They're not just throwing
apps into a store
and hoping for the best.
They know what their
users are doing.
They're adapting to what
their users' requirements are
and the users' needs
are on the fly.
And all of that can be
driven off of Analytics.
So importantly, and
one of the things
that we're announcing
at Cloud Next,
is that we're trying to bring
the ease of use of Firebase
together with the full range of
Google Platform, Google Cloud
Platform, services.
So if you're building
mobile applications,
we really think Firebase
is a great offering for you
to get started, for you to be
able to maybe build everything
that you need.
But if you start needing
the backend scalability
of the Google Cloud
Platform, then there
is a path for you to get there.
And a small side note is that
scalability is something,
to me, that's very
important, because it's
often miscommunicated.
Because when you say
the word "scalability,"
you think being able
to go big and being
able to go big really quickly.
And that's only
half of the truth.
The real power of the
Google Cloud Platform
is not just being able
to scale up very quickly,
it's also being able to
scale back down very quickly
and only pay for the compute
capacity that you're using.
And there's one example of
this that I like to share.
It was a project that I worked
on when I first joined Google.
And it was for a boy band, OK?
And anybody heard of the
boy band "One Direction?"
Aah!
And what they did
was they put together
this online event on YouTube
for the release of a new album.
And it was, like, a
seven-hour livestream.
And during this seven-hour
livestream, every 10 minutes,
the band would ask somebody
to go over to an app,
to a second screen
application, and answer
a question so that they could
have the best-- they could find
out who were the best
and who were the most
knowledgeable "One
Direction" fans.
So think about that in
terms of scalability, right?
You have a boy band with
millions of fans and millions
of people watching a stream
and nobody looking at the app.
And then the band
says, go to the app.
What happens?
Millions of people
go to the app.
And your traffic goes from
nothing to massive spike.
And then the people
answer the question.
And what do they do?
They close the app.
So your traffic goes
back down again.
And if you think about this
in terms of scalability
and capacity planning,
you know, typically, you
would build something that
maybe could handle this capacity
and hope that the spike
doesn't penetrate it.
But you have nothing.
You have a spike.
You go down.
You have nothing.
You have a spike.
You go down.
But you're paying
for all of this space
below the capacity when
you're not using it.
And one of the really neat
things about the Google Cloud
Platform and about App Engine,
which this was built on,
was that the number of
virtual machines that
were used to manage the site
followed this curve precisely.
So when we ended up
finally shipping this thing
and running it, it
was massively used,
had a huge amount of traffic.
And I'm not allowed
to share how much it
costs to actually run the App
Engine instances for this.
But a few of us went out and had
a couple of drinks afterwards.
And I don't even drink,
and the drinks bill
was higher than the cloud bill.
So if you manage scalability,
and you scale up,
and you scaled back
down effectively--
and that kind of scale that the
Google Cloud Platform gives you
is a very, very powerful tool.
So coming back to
Firebase, what we're doing
is we're really bringing
these two services together.
We're bringing the
ease of development
and the ease of use of Firebase.
But it's not a silo in
between the two of these.
You have a glide
path from A to B
if you need to get
that backend logic
and you need to build
that kind of scale.
So this is how we
typically look at Firebase.
And here's how we like to talk
about it, the three pillars
that I mentioned.
So there are services to help
you develop your application--
a realtime database,
authentication,
cloud messaging, storage,
hosting, test lab, crash
reporting, and functions.
I'm going to talk about each of
these in this talk in detail.
And then there are
the other pillars
that we're not going to
go into in a lot of detail
in this talk.
But if you have any
questions about them,
come see me afterwards.
And that's notifications
for growing your application
through re-engaging your users.
There's a remote
configuration, which
is a personal favorite of mine.
And that's a way that you can
store values, global values,
for your application on a server
and have them driven off of--
have them driven
off of Analytics.
There's app indexing where
users using the Google Search
app on their phone,
if they're searching
for content that's
in your app, they
should be able to find your app.
Because they've already made the
choice to download and install
your app instead of randomly
discovering it at some
point again in the future.
Dynamic links are
really smart links
that will allow user A to
share content with user B.
And even the content
context can be taken
through an install session.
Now, that's a bit of a mouthful.
So if I were to explain
that, it's like--
so for example, I
really like to eat,
and my wife really
likes to cook.
It's a great arrangement.
And if she discovers
some really interesting
recipes online and she wants
to send me these recipes--
and then she'll find, OK,
here's a recipe for X.
And it's in this application.
Why don't you take a look
at it and see if it's
something that you would like--
well, what happens then?
She would probably
send me the recipe.
And then I would go onto
the Play Store on my phone.
And then I search.
You know, it's in Frank
Puff's cooking application,
so I start searching in
Frank's cooking application.
Frank's here in the front row,
so I'm giving him a hard time.
So I'd search Frank's
cooking application.
And then I find it.
And then I install it.
And then that takes
a few minutes.
And then it finishes installing.
And then I open it up.
And what was the recipe again?
So that's the idea
of the dynamic links
was that if you had
sent me a dynamic link,
then the context of that
recipe would be maintained
through my install session.
So again, as an app developer,
that's really useful for me,
because it will
help my app grow.
Because when person A shares
something with person B,
person B gets the context
throughout that entire session.
And it makes for a
better experience.
App Invites is
another one of these.
It's like where friends help
friends discover great apps.
I have an awesome
16-year-old son.
And what my awesome
16-year-old son spends way too
much time doing is
cruising the Play Store
looking for great free games.
And then when he finds
the good free games,
we will send them to me.
And because he's kind of
already curated them for me,
I know they're
going to be great.
And if an app developer
had built these games
using App Invites, as soon
as he hits the Share button,
I'm going to be at
the top of the list.
Because the
intelligence behind this
says that, hey, when you
share, this guy, your dad,
will take the game,
and will install it,
and will usually enjoy it.
And of course, his
mom's going to be
at the bottom of the list,
because she will always
say stop playing games,
stop playing too many games.
And so all of these are
tied together by Analytics,
and you can earn off of them.
But I want to focus
on the left-hand side,
the develop technologies.
And so Analytics first--
the idea behind Analytics is--
I used to be a
development manager.
And I don't know if many
of you have probably
sat in one of these meetings
where you've built an app,
and you want to ship
the application.
And then your
marketing people say,
well, we want this
set of analytics
to see if our
campaigns are working.
And then the salespeople
say, well, we
want this set of
analytics to see
if, you know, we're
meeting our goals,
if we're hitting
our commissions,
if the right people
are buying it.
And the engineering
people are saying, well,
we want this set of
analytics, because we
want to see the performance
of the application.
And we want to see if
we've optimized everything
that we need to optimize for
the best user experience.
And the CEO is probably
saying, well, I
want this set of analytics,
because this part of the app
was my pet project,
and I want everybody
to see this part of the app,
and all of these things.
And then you usually sit.
And you have to compromise.
And what's the usual compromise?
You've got to do
everything, right?
And how many times
have-- have any of you
ever sat in one
of those meetings?
Yeah, I see a few hands.
And then you end up
saying, hey, look,
if I need to ship
everything, we're
not going to be able to ship
the application on time.
You know, I can't put all
of these analytics in there,
or we're not going
to be able to ship.
And it becomes ugly.
And there's compromises and
all those kinds of thing.
So one of the nice things with
Firebase Analytics is that all
of the common event- and
user-centric things that can
happen in your application
are collected for you behind
the scenes for free--
not just monetary free, but
you don't write any code.
You link in the
Analytics libraries.
And all the possible
things you could
imagine, like opening
this activity,
closing that activity,
those types of things--
in-app purchases, all
that type of stuff--
is collected for you for free.
So that's number one advantage.
Number two advantage
then, of course,
is that you can use the
analytics that you're gathering
about your users
to drive behavior
in some of the other
functions of Firebase.
And I'll talk through
that in just a moment.
So here's an example
that, last year,
for Google I/O, a Googler
built this Bingo Blast game.
And he put the
analytics into that.
And we just collected a whole
bunch of analytics from that
without writing any code.
And these are some
of the things that we
were able to tell from it.
So I just grabbed this
screenshot from it.
So for example, the one that I
always find much amusement from
is the amount of in-app
purchases there you can see.
And so in this case,
his Android application
had 22,700 monthly actives.
And they spend $2,000.
And his iOS users, he
only had 5,000 of them,
and they spent
$3,000, all right?
So there's the old urban
legend that, you know,
the iOS users spend more money.
But well, here you go.
Here was our analytics
to prove this.
And he was able to
gather this kind of intel
without spending a
lot of time coding.
Now, I mentioned
there's a lot of--
common events will be
captured for you for free.
You don't write
any code for that.
You're probably thinking,
well, what about a thing
that my app does that
only my app does.
Maybe I'm building
a game, and I see
that everybody quits
the game after level 3
because the boss is
too difficult to beat.
So that's at least a feedback
that I've gotten from my users.
So you could build a
custom analytic for that.
And unfortunately,
that does require
writing a little bit of code.
We can't predict all of
that ahead of time for you.
But we've made the
APIs very, very easy
so that you can write that
code and build those kinds
of analytics into it.
So on to the develop here.
First of all is the
realtime database.
Now, the realtime database is
a cloud-hosted NoSQL database.
It's a very, very
smart type of database
so that you've got
synchronization and conflict
resolution.
So if you think about it, we
live in a multi-device world.
Many of us have a phone, a
tablet, maybe a smartwatch,
a robot--
you know, these kind of
things that are going
to be able to access our data.
Now, if we are building
an application that
requires access to the
data, or maybe on my phone,
I'm going to change
something, and I
need to see that updated
on my tablet, that's
the idea of how the
synchronization works
and how the conflict resolution
works within Firebase.
This is all done for
you behind the scenes.
It's an event-driven database.
So when something happens, if I
make a change to a set of data,
an event will fire.
The application running
on my other device
will receive that event.
And then it can synchronize
its state to the data
based on receiving that.
And most importantly,
and sometimes overlooked,
is that you access it
directly from your app.
So a lot of time, if
you're writing an app
or if you're building
something, you generally
have to build a back end.
And you have to write a lot
of code on the back end.
And more often than
not, you're simple CRUD,
simple CRUD operations where
you're reading, writing,
updating, deleting data.
And so you need to maintain
a back end for that.
And you need to build
And you need a totally
different set of skills
for building a back end.
And one of the nice things about
the Firebase remote database--
or the realtime database--
is that this is just code
that's running in your app.
So you have the same code base.
And the Backend as a Service of
the Firebase realtime database
manages all of that for you.
So you've got that single code
base, that single set of skills
to make your life easier.
Now earlier, I
mentioned, of course,
Firebase is working
very closely with Cloud.
And if you do want to
build a back end in Cloud
and you want to get the
scalability of that,
or if you want to get the
logic, the programming logic
that, sometimes,
you only do want
to put on a back
end, then of course,
there are technologies to
make them work together.
And we'll be talking about
them a little bit later
in this presentation.
But a clear use case for
that that I always see is--
and I used to work in
the financial analytics,
not to be confused
with the analytics
I spoke about earlier on.
And a lot of
financial companies,
they have a set of analytics
for a particular company
that they can use
to measure and get
a temperature for that company.
And that's their crown jewels.
They're not going to distribute
that in an application.
They want to keep
that on a back end.
that for themselves
so that nobody else can
see those analytics.
And you know, that's
a great use case
for where you may want to
put code on a back end,
and not in Firebase, and
not on the front end.
So you've got the option
to be able to do both.
But when you're building with
the Firebase realtime database,
you can do that from
within your client app
without needing that
back end at all.
And here's how
synchronization works
that I spoke about earlier on.
You've got multiple devices.
You've got one database.
And the synchronization
fans out between them
because of how the database
is built to be event-driven.
And another really
neat one is the fact
that it has offline access.
So if you are building
an application
and you are using Firebase,
but you don't have connectivity
at this moment in
time, but you're
writing to that Firebase,
it will get cached.
And then the next
time you come online
and you reconnect,
then the data can
be synchronized between them.
So I was doing a talk earlier
on today about geolocation.
And I used this little
guy to demo geolocation.
And one of the
questions that I always
get, if you doing geolocation
and you're storing it
in Firebase, what happens when
you go into a tunnel, right?
And then you can't dial home.
And you can't store
your location.
And you can't get these details.
And that's where
something like Firebase
is a really good
solution for that.
Because you're getting your
geolocation information.
You're storing it.
You're not connected.
You come out of the tunnel.
You get reconnected.
And the data can
get re-synchronized.
So then, there's authentication.
User management and
authentication, of course,
is really important.
If you want any kind
of custom experience
in your app for your end user,
even if it's just a high score
table in a game or
something along those lines,
you need to be able
to identify your user.
And your user wants to
know that their identity
details are secure.
They don't want to be able to
give tons of information to you
that you may not need.
I mean, do they need your
social security number enable
to generate a high score table?
Probably not.
And so-- maybe they do.
There might be hash in there.
I don't know.
So the idea is that,
with authentication,
we offer, in Firebase
Auth, a number
of different federated
identity providers--
Facebook, Twitter, GitHub,
and of course, Google.
And so if you want your user to
be able to sign in with them,
then you can almost
effortlessly implement
that in your application.
The user signs in, for example,
with their Twitter account.
Twitter sends back
a token saying
that, yes, this is the
user Bob Smith or whatever.
So then you can customize
your application to them.
And then you, as a business, are
not gathering any information
from that user, which
is very user-friendly.
Because how many times do you
want to fill out a form saying,
this is my name,
this is my password,
this is my address, as an
end user, when you already
have a Twitter account,
or a Facebook account,
or a Google account, or
something like that--
so again, to make it
very, very user-friendly.
But of course, if you want to be
able to identify users yourself
and not federate out
to them, then there's
the email and password
authentication
built in to the
Firebase Auth where
you would gather their
username and their password
that they want to use to
sign in to your application.
And then Firebase stores that.
And then they can
sign in with Firebase.
But there's also a really
neat thing called--
we have an open source
library for Firebase Auth
for handling user flows.
Because if you
think about it, it
can get really, really complex.
You open up an
application, and you want
to sign in to the application.
What happens next?
Maybe you want to sign
in with a Google account.
Well, there are
many of you who have
more than one Google account.
Which one are you going
to sign in with, right?
And so, OK-- or
maybe you want to--
you don't have a
Google account, and you
need to sign up for
a Google account
in order to be able to sign
in with the application.
So how do you handle all of
that, or the same for Twitter
and others like that?
So there's all of these
very complex flows
that a user needs
to go through to be
able to sign in to
your application
or sign up for your application.
So we've open-sourced
the library
where we've put years of
research into optimizing these,
particularly for Google IDs.
And there's an open source
library for Firebase Auth--
it's on GitHub--
that you'll be able to do.
And you can drop that
into your application.
And then all of those potential
have been implemented for you.
And again, thinking of the
habits of the highly successful
developers that
you're not writing
all of this code for yourself.
You're being able to take
upon what we've done,
the work that we've done
and that we've open-sourced,
to make life a whole lot
easier for your uses.
Cloud Storage for
Firebase-- if you're
building an application
that needs to store files,
then Cloud Storage is
really handy for you.
Maybe it's a social
media application,
and you need to store
user pictures, or videos,
of those kind of things.
Instead of building
your own infrastructure
for hosting files and then
thinking of all the complex use
cases, edge caching for
people around the world,
or what happens if you're
storing a large file,
and then the person's
downloading it,
and their connection breaks,
as can happen with mobile,
as you walk between access
points and access point,
all of these kind of things--
all of this kind of logic
was built.
I think, Eric, again,
yesterday, in the keynote,
said, hey, we spent
$30 billion on building
this infrastructure.
Why should you build
it for yourself?
And this is one of the benefits
of that Cloud infrastructure is
that the Cloud Storage for
Firebase is built upon that.
So one of the
benefits of that is
like, you get
disconnected-- what happens?
So 2 gigabyte file,
you get disconnected
after 1.9 gigabytes--
do you want
to start downloading again?
No.
So there are APIs for that.
There are Cloud APIs for that.
So you could have that kind
of file management built
in your Firebase applications,
built in for you.
One of my personal
favorites-- and I geek out
over this one a lot-- is
Firebase Cloud Messaging.
So as of--
I think it was--
November last year,
we announced that we
send over 1 trillion
messages using Firebase Cloud
Messaging every week.
And the vast majority
of those messages
are received by
connected devices
in less than 500 milliseconds.
So there's a massive
infrastructure there
that you can use to send
realtime or near realtime
messages for your users,
and it doesn't cost a dime.
It's completely free of charge.
It works cross-platform.
So it works on iOS.
It works on the web.
It works on Android.
And this is something
that you can
use to drive user interaction.
Like, one partner
that we spoke with,
it's a company that does
notifications for people
that use public transport.
And so this is kind
of handy where,
like if you live in a city, and
you rely on public transport,
and there are delays in
the public transport,
then you can get notified
by this application
that such and such a line
is closed down today or such
and such a line is
on a half hour delay.
But if you don't live in that
city and you still use the app,
you don't want to receive
those notifications.
So there's intelligence
in the messaging platform.
So notifications can be sent
for things such as topics.
So for example, if
I live in London
and I'm interested in
the London Underground,
or if I live in New York and
I'm interested in the New York
subway, I should only be
receiving notifications
about London if I live in London
and only receive notifications
about New York if I live there.
So there's that versatile
messaging-- sorry,
that versatile way of
targeting your messages so
that the right users
get the message.
And like I said, for
connected applications,
it's usually less
than 500 milliseconds.
And it's getting bigger,
and bigger, and bigger
all the time.
And it's pretty cool.
And it's totally free of charge.
Remote Config I spoke a
little bit about earlier on.
I find it really cool, because
it's server-side variables
that you can modify without
redeploying your application.
And they're integrated
with Analytics.
Let me give an example.
Say you build an
application that's
an e-commerce application.
And as part of this, you
provide a standard discount
to all of your users.
So for the majority
of your users,
the standard
discount might be 0%.
But some people--
like, maybe you
want to grow the
application in Canada.
So you say, hey, for
people in Canada,
we're going to give
a discount of 10%.
And then, say you
realize that people
who make three
purchases in the app
tend to make a lot more
after their third one.
So people who have made
three purchases in the app,
we're going to give
them a 15% discount.
And then, let's
just say, OK, women
tend to shop more in
this app than men do.
So let's give women a
20% discount in this app.
Now, think of all that logic.
Think of all that if this,
then that, if this, then that.
And then you suddenly
realize that you
don't want to give the
Canadians that discount anymore.
You want to change
it, all right?
So what do you do?
Do you ship a new app, and you
do all the if this, then that,
and you do all the testing?
You could do that, but
that's a lot of work.
With something like Remote
Config tied with Analytics,
then each of those
conditions that I spoke about
can generate an audience.
And then for that audience,
you can set the value
to be a certain amount.
For the Canadians,
it could be 10%,
for women, 20%,
those kind of things.
And then when your app reads the
variable off of Remote Config,
because it's driven
by Analytics,
your app can just get
that variable and then
can execute on that right away.
And if you need to
change that variable,
you change it in one
place on the server
without reshipping
your application.
So it opens up
really, really cool,
really interesting
scenarios, particularly when
it's tied to Analytics, for
some good, fun stuff that you
can do with your applications.
Another one, Test
Lab for Android, is--
OK, I'll do a quick survey.
How many people here
have a Pixel XL?
Oh wow, three?
OK.
I usually ask that,
and there's none.
OK, so for those of you who
don't have a Pixel XL, how do
you test your applications
if you're building them
for a Pixel XL, right?
The vast majority of the--
maybe 200 people in the room.
So 97% and a--
98.5% of us don't
have a Pixel XL.
How do we test for that?
Or what if you live
in a country where
the Pixel XL isn't available
or particular devices aren't
available?
Like maybe you
live in-- maybe you
build-- you're a
Chinese developer,
but you're building for
the American market,
and you don't have access to
American phones, or vice versa.
What if they aren't
available to you?
What do you do?
Do you create this huge farm of
devices so you can test them?
So again, one of the habits
of the highly successful
developers is being able to
test on a variety of devices.
But it's really difficult
to send people on a plane
to other parts of the
world to buy devices
that aren't available to you.
So Test Lab for
Android is where we
have created a suite of both
virtual and physical machines
so that you, as an
Android developer,
can upload your APK
of your application.
And you can have it tested
by a suite of robo-tests
that we've designed.
Or you can design
the actual test
that you want to
have done on it.
And we'll send you back a
report on how it performed.
And we'll send you
back screenshots
and those kind of things.
And there's one really
fun, innovative use of this
that I heard about that--
has anybody here
heard of Udacity?
They're a training company.
Yeah, cool-- so
quite a few of you.
So for one of Udacity's
certifications,
they have an exam
that they do for you
to pass the certification.
And what they do is they give
you an incomplete Android
application.
And you have to fix the
bugs in the application.
And you have to finish
the application off.
So when you do that, you
upload the APK to them.
They actually run
it through Test Lab.
So they've written a
suite of robo-tests.
So instead of a human
looking at this application
to say that Frank actually
finished this activity,
and he did it correctly,
and this button works--
you know, those kind of
things-- that they actually
have a robo-test to
do that for them.
And to me, it a scenario that--
I don't think we thought of that
when we were building Test Lab,
right?
And it's just how people
have innovated on it.
I just find it's really
fun, and it's really cool.
Another one, Crash
Reporting-- the number one
reason why you get bad reviews
in an App Store or a Play Store
is your app crashes, all right?
App crashing is a bad thing.
But how do you fix it?
I have this scenario
where there's an app
that I was working on for a
show in Korea last summer.
And before I went to Korea, I
sent it to some people in Korea
to test it.
And it didn't work.
And I'm like, OK, what
does "it didn't work" mean?
And they were like,
it didn't work.
So how can I fix that?
I mean, what's the
developer's usual answer?
Works on my computer, you know?
So it's like, how do I fix that?
So with Crash
Reporting, thankfully,
when I migrated the
application over to Firebase
and used Firebase
Crash Reporting,
then I was able to basically
get a detailed stack trace back
every time it failed.
And from the
detailed stack trace,
I was able to figure out
why it was failing in Korea
and it wasn't failing
on my machine.
And I was able to fix
it before I went there.
So when I was doing
the demo, I was
able to spend my time
preparing for the demo
instead of trying to fix a bug--
you know, so those
kind of things.
And of course--
and as you'll see,
these three words,
"integrated with Analytics,"
is built into almost anything.
So as you're crash
reporting-- maybe
you've got a million people
using it, and 100,000 of them
are having crashes.
By using Analytics, you
can slice and dice them
into audiences.
So you can figure out which
audience is getting the crash.
So then you can figure out why.
And then you can fix it,
and deploy a new version,
and hopefully stop
getting bad reviews.
And then the other one
is Firebase Hosting.
And this one makes me
smile a little bit.
Because whenever I talk
about Firebase Hosting,
a lot of people
think, eh, that's
a little bit of an
afterthought, right?
Because Firebase
Hosting, what it is is
it allows you to
serve static assets
like HTML, JavaScript, images.
It's Secure Sockets
Layer by default.
So you can deliver a secure
site and save yourself
all the hassle of
dealing with certificates
and all that kind of thing.
And you can map a
custom domain to it.
But often, when I
speak to developers,
they go, yeah, but I don't
really want a static site.
You can't really do that
much with a static site.
So I wanted to come up with
a gratuitous demo that shows,
maybe this is an
interesting thing
that you can do
with a static site.
So if we can switch
to my demo machine.
OK, so as a hobby,
I'm a CG artist.
And I'm a writer.
And for one of my
books, when trying
to sell it to a publisher,
they asked me to say, hey,
can you send us
some visualizations
of the characters, and
maybe what the characters
look like so we can get
a feel for the scenario,
we can get a feel for
some of the things that
are going on in the story.
So I've been doing that, and
I've been working with CG.
So I thought, hmm,
Firebase Hosting-- maybe I
can do something interesting.
So the biggest possible image
I can render was a 10,000
by 10,000 image.
So that's 100 million
pixels, all right?
So those 100 million
pixels, I stored them
on Firebase Storage--
sorry, on a Firebase
Hosting site.
And then the Firebase
Hosting site is at this URL,
seadragontestsfd
06e.firebaseapp.com.
And I'm on the conference Wi-Fi.
How long do you think
it's going to take
before you can see the image?
Live demo-- drum roll--
Frank looks worried.
Drum roll.
All right?
OK, so I cheated.
So I haven't downloaded all 100
million pixels of the image.
So there was a JavaScript
library called Seadragon
that I put and I put
onto Firebase Hosting.
And with Seadragon, it
kind of works a little bit
like Google Maps that
you slice your image up
into tiles, and tiles of
different zoom levels.
So based on the zoom
level that you're
doing right now-- and in this
case, I'm zoomed right out.
And in real terms, I'm
probably seeing, maybe,
800 by 800 pixels.
So it's only
downloading the tiles
that are appropriate for that.
So I got it really quickly.
But just to show
you that this really
is a 100-megapixel image,
can you see her eye?
All right, I'm going to zoom
in, and I'm going to zoom in,
and I'm going to zoom in,
and I'm going to zoom in.
So we can even see the
reflection in her eye,
all right?
So when I rendered this
image, I ray traced it.
So whatever was behind
the virtual camera
got ray traced so that we could
see the reflection in her eye.
And this is just
static JavaScript
with a bunch of tiles
running in Firebase Hosting.
And if I zoom out
again for a moment,
you can see individual
hairs in the eyelash
and that kind of thing.
So this really is a
100-megapixel image.
And you can see these
monitors in the background.
Well, you can't read
the text on them.
But if I zoom in,
you can actually
read the text on
them-- hopefully it
shows up on the
projector-- where
it says "comparative,
precious metals, 26 meters."
Because that's like a scanner
on the ship behind her,
that kind of thing.
So this is static hosting in
Firebase Hosting, you know?
For something like this,
these are JavaScript libraries
called OpenSeadragon.
So I put the JavaScript
libraries on there.
I put an HTML page calling
those JavaScript libraries.
I used a tool in Linux
to slice this image.
So my 100-megapixel image got
sliced into about 8,000 tiles.
With Firebase tools, I upload
all those tiles in one shot.
And I have a website to
do something like this.
So there's lots of
really, really cool stuff
that you can do with
Firebase Hosting
even though it's just
still static hosting.
Don't overlook it.
I think it's really cool, the
kind of things that you can do.
All right, so can we switch
back to the slides please?
So today, we then announced
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
And anybody excited
about Cloud Functions?
Show of hands.
Whoo.
So we've been working
really, really hard
on this for a long time.
And it's been, in many ways,
the number one request.
I mean, it's all very nice that
we can store data in Firebase.
But can we do something with it?
Can we do analytics on it?
If, then, an event changes--
sorry, if a data item
changes-- from A to B,
can we run some code
in response to that?
Can we send a message from
Google Cloud Messaging when
value reaches a certain amount?
All of these questions, that's
what Cloud Functions are all
about.
So you'll be hearing a lot more
about Cloud Functions today
and later today.
And I believe we have a
code lab downstairs for it.
Is that right, Frank?
OK.
We have a code lab for
it in the code labs area.
So you can go and play with
it, and you can test with it.
We've been so excited
by this, but we've
been holding our tongue for
this event so that we can--
you know, so you guys can go and
you can really play with this.
And to me.
It's one of the things that
really brings your ability
to build with Firebase
to the next level.
When you start looking into
these, it's pretty cool stuff.
So that's like the quick
whistlestop tour of what's
available in Firebase.
But like I've mentioned,
it's really, really important
to think about Firebase
as part of Cloud overall.
You know, Firebase
is our platform
for building mobile applications
that work with Cloud.
There are some other
sessions here about Cloud
that you might be
interested in if you
want to be a Cloud developer.
But talking about Cloud,
some of the functions
that are within Cloud, some
of the aspects of Cloud that
are available to
you as a developer
that, should you want to
migrate to the next step
beyond Firebase--
one of those is Cloud Functions.
Does it sound familiar?
All right?
So it's very similar to the
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
But this is Cloud Functions,
which are lightweight,
event-based microservices.
Again, they're
completely serverless.
So if you are
building stuff that
runs in the cloud
on the back end,
if you're building
stuff in App Engine,
stuff that uses Pub/Sub,
if you're building
stuff that uses
the Google virtual machines
and Google Compute Engine,
then you've got
microservices that
are event-based
that you can start
using to orchestrate
these things to do
interesting scenarios.
And it's up to you to decide the
scenarios for your application.
But one of the nice things
about them is automatic scaling.
Remember, earlier on, when I
mentioned the "One Direction"
example, that that was
really, really cool where
you can scale up quickly.
But what, to me, made
that a special one
is that you could scale
back down quickly,
and you're only paying
for what you use.
That kind of automated
scaling, that kind of stuff
is available to you if you're
using Cloud Functions to build
your cloud applications.
And open and familiar, and one
of the neat things about this
if you're a developer,
is that you actually
script these using JavaScript.
And they run on
a Node.js engine.
So if you want to
build, and test,
and try and figure
out your script
and figure out your logic before
you're connected to the cloud,
before you're dealing
with cloud stuff,
then you can do that
with the Cloud Functions.
Node.js is just
JavaScript programming.
Next up is App Engine.
And the "One Direction"
example that I mentioned,
that was built on App Engine.
And App Engine is a Platform
as a Service offering.
So anybody familiar
with App Engine?
OK, quite a few of you-- cool.
And it's got a variety
of development languages
you can use, Java, PHP,
Python, those kind of things,
Go, of course, as well.
And again, that has
the automatic scaling.
So you think about it
as microinstances of VMs
that don't have the capability
of a full virtual machine
and operating
system, but they're
programmable, which is what
makes them microinstances.
And as a result, you
can create them quickly,
and you can destroy
them quickly.
And then you get all the
infrastructure benefits--
Eric Schmidt $30
billion comment--
you know, the infrastructure
benefits like load balancing,
health checking if you're
running them constantly,
being able to log
their behavior.
In the "One Direction"
example, logging really, really
helped us early on.
Because we couldn't figure
out why some of the things
we were doing when we were
testing were going wrong.
And it turned out that
we had some fans who
were such superfans of the
band that they figured out
the URL of the site that we
were hosting the quiz on.
And they were trying
to get in early.
And they were breaking some of
our tests and stuff like that.
And maybe we should have
used the fourth bullet point
for them, and that's security.
Because your instances,
your App Engine instances,
are always secured.
And of course, there's great
developer support, like I said.
There's a multitude of
languages that it runs on.
And they're pretty easy to
develop for and build for.
Compute Engine,
then, is your ability
to create a virtual machine
and run that in the cloud.
And then you can scale
it out accordingly.
One of the things I really
enjoy doing is-- you saw,
my demo earlier on-- is
doing CG development.
And sometimes if I'm going
to render an image-- like,
that one wasn't photoreal.
But sometimes when
I want to render
an image, a photoreal image,
it can take 30 or 40 hours
to render a big image.
But if I spin up
a virtual machine,
upload my stuff to that,
get that to start rendering,
then I'm not tying
up my home machines.
And the machine that I usually
use at home to render it on
runs an operating system that's
not on this silver machine.
And it tends to crash a lot.
So I won't say its name.
So I like to upload
them to the cloud.
And as a result, I
can fire and forget.
I can put them up there,
render them, get an image back.
So Compute Engine's really
handy for things like that.
You can have Windows
in the cloud.
You can have Linux in the
cloud, those kind of things.
As Urs mentioned this
morning, how it charges,
its minute-level.
So you're not paying
excessive money for capacity
that you're not using.
And as a result,
it's very flexible.
Container Engine--
so I'll personally
admit that I don't
use containers a lot--
or I didn't until recently.
And one of the really nice
things about Container
is that if you're using
full operating systems
and you're running applications
on full operating systems,
you can have a lot
of dependencies.
And then, so if you try to
build an application that
runs on one machine,
it doesn't necessarily
run on another machine.
So this little
guy, this robot, he
runs on a Raspberry
Pi backplane.
And so there's some
Python scripts on him
that I use to turn him
into an autonomous robot,
and to do geolocation, and
all that kind of stuff.
But I have a Linux
machine at home
that I use for
developing this stuff.
And his Raspberry
Pi board uses Linux.
So I spent a lot of time
writing code, testing code,
doing geolocation, make sure
things were working fine.
And then I deployed it
to the Linux on that guy,
and it didn't work, OK?
Because there's a thing
in Linux called AWK.
And the AWK flavor of the Linux
that the Raspberry Pi runs
was very different from AWK
flavor on my desktop machine
that I was using to develop.
And I didn't know this.
So I ended up having to
rewrite half of my code
to get it to work on this guy.
And that's one of
the things containers
are really handy for.
Like for me, it was, I
have a development machine,
and I have a single robot.
But what if you have a cluster
farm of a thousand servers,
and then it turns out that
those thousand servers, there's
version drift between them?
There's different
versions of, maybe,
operating systems, or patches,
and all that kind of stuff.
And that's the goal
behind containers,
where the idea of
a container is you
can create a script for what
an operating system's supposed
to look like.
And then you can spin up
operating systems from that.
You can spin up virtual machines
with those operating systems.
And then you can have
that consistent set.
For me, it was just a
case of a single one.
But I can't imagine
what it would be like
if I had had to make changes to
handle with thousands of them.
And that's what Container
Engine's all about.
It allows you to quickly
set up these clusters.
You can manage
them declaratively.
And that flexibility, if
you need to make a change,
you could maybe make a
change to the entire cluster
to bring in a new dependency
that you didn't realize
that you had previously needed.
So these are some
of the services
that are available on Cloud.
And you, as a mobile
developer, can
take advantage of all of these.
And the thing that ties them
all together from the Cloud
perspective is Cloud Endpoints.
So Cloud Endpoints
allow you to build
an API that wraps
your cloud services
and then make that
API accessible
to your mobile applications.
So if you're running
stuff on App Engine,
if you're running stuff
on containers, if--
you know, the
Kubernetes engine, GKE,
is what we use for
managing containers.
If you're running
your stuff in that,
then the idea is you can
wrap them with an API
that's callable from
a mobile back end--
or from a mobile
application, sorry--
so that then, these
become your back end.
So if you're not using Firebase
for things like functions,
but you're using
Cloud for functions,
or you're building logic
that runs on App Engine,
and you need to
easily be able to call
that from a mobile application,
Cloud Endpoints are
your friend.
They're a choose your own
framework kind of thing.
So if you want to build
in Java for Android,
or if you're building in
Objective-C or Swift for iOS,
then you can call these guys.
And like they say, they provide
that wrapping service for you
to be able to build your
mobile applications.
So that's a quick
tour of the things
that you need to
consider when building
mobile applications,
what we believe
are the habits of highly
successful mobile developers,
why we've built Firebase
the way that we've built it
with the services that we
have done so, and also,
hopefully to show you that,
if you're going down Firebase
and you're going down
the Firebase route,
but you want to be able to
move to something bigger
and scalable and have
logic on your back end,
Cloud is available to you.
And as an application
developer in Firebase,
you are also able to use that.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And if we have any questions,
we can take them at the mics.
AUDIENCE: Hello, I
have one question.
Do you have any plans
on expanding Firebase
to over-the-top solutions?
LAURENCE MORONEY: When you
say over-the-top solutions--
AUDIENCE: Apple TV, or
Android TV, or Roku.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I mean, I can't
comment on any specific plans.
But Firebase, of course,
has web-based interfaces.
So with a web call, you can
read and write to the database.
Not all of the functions
that I showed you have web.
Like remote config doesn't
yet have a web interface.
But on the whole, you
could make API calls
in that way with web interfaces.
AUDIENCE: All right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned the
Firebase Cloud Storage.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Could you go
into a little more detail
on where those
files actually live
and what scopes are
involved to access those?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
So to the best of my knowledge--
I don't really dive
down deep in them.
But we have Google
Cloud Storage.
And Google Cloud
Storage has data centers
around the world and edge
caches around the world.
And they're stored there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So when
you're asking about scopes
to access them, my
understanding would
be that the scope that you allow
your user as a Firebase user
is what would give them
the permission token
to be able to access them
on the Cloud back end also.
So if you've got a million
users of your application
and you want all million
to see one set of files,
but a individual user
only to see a
different set of files,
that's done using
the Firebase Auth.
And it works with the Cloud back
end to be able to manage that.
And I see Frank nodding,
so I think I got it right.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: He's my test.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: So currently,
on Firebase, I
see there is a small
restriction, which
is you can only log up
to 500 events and only up
to 25 user properties.
And they are not even deletable.
So do you have any plans to
remove those restrictions?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sorry, which
restrictions, specifically?
I didn't hear.
AUDIENCE: So for Analytics, you
can log only up to 500 events.
And for remote config--
and for user properties, sorry--
you can only have up to 25
of them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
AUDIENCE: So are there
any plans to remove those?
Because I feel like it's
easy to hit those limits.
And especially with
the user properties,
you can't delete them as of now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
We're not allowed to
speculate on future stuff,
but we understand that
that's a requirement.
And it's one of the requirements
that we're working on.
And obviously, we have
Google I/O coming up
in a couple of months.
And we're working on some new
stuff for Firebase for that.
So there may be some
new announcements then,
but I can't really
speculate on a specific one.
But understand that's it's
a big requirement that we've
received.
And we're taking it seriously.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I just wanted to
ask you if Firebase
has any plans of
incorporating A/B testing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: A/B testing?
Absolutely, via remote config.
So the remote config
that I spoke about
is perfect for A/B testing.
So again, thinking about,
it's a server-side variable
that's driven by Analytics.
So you could say, OK,
let's set the variable to--
I don't know--
for the background
color of the main activity.
That's going to be red
for people in Canada
and blue for people in the US.
And then you can perform
an A/B test like that.
And then, using
Analytics, you can also
measure how people have
interacted with it.
AUDIENCE: How would we know
which particular cohort--
I mean, which
particular, let's say,
conversion corresponds to
which particular cohort that's
been set in remote config?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So--
I'm trying to think.
So if you define an audience in
Analytics and you specify that,
again, just using the flippant
example of the background color
of an activity as
an example, then you
know that audience A has red
and audience B has green.
So then, when you are-- you
can set another analytic
on the application
that says, people
who have a red background, are
they doing favorable activity
like spending time
in the application,
or doing in-app purchases
on the application,
or something like that.
And then measure that.
And you could correlate
the two against each other.
It's the only way I
could think of right now
to do something like that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just
wanted to figure out
a way to connect both
the things, so you know.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
could connect it off
of the remote config variable.
Because you know that audience
A has remote config variable
red, and audience B has blue.
So then you could
say, OK, when I
got red, who spent time
in the application on red,
or who did an in-app
purchase on red.
And then you could create
a custom analytic for that
and then measure that.
So it's almost like
the remote config
variable is the integration
point between the two
audiences.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Does the Test Lab--
what testing does that do?
I was looking for something
that does application response
time or performance testing.
Does that test that as well?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I'm not sure if it
measures actual performance.
I think, like for common
things like the initial open,
and initial close,
and quit, I think
it reports back the time to
open and that kind of thing.
But then, in-app performance
like moving from activity A
to activity B, I don't think
it does that out of the box.
But you might be able to
create a robo-test for that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
My recommendation
would be-- in the ask the
experts area downstairs,
there's a guy called Doug.
And he's our Test Lab guru.
He's the expert.
And he's been spending
a lot of time--
guy with a little goatee beard.
You can't miss him.
And he'll probably be best
able to answer that question.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
All right, thanks.
Time for one more?
Nope, we're good?
OK, so check out the code labs.
Have a play with Firebase.
And if you have any
questions, come see me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]